they'll take their swings off
32-year-old alex cobb
and he takes strike three so cobb
with a strikeout to start his evening
well that's the one that's the
two-seamer he starts inside to the left
henderson it's all about fastball
command to be able to get ahead he can
finish with that fast ball he finished
with the splitter too but you can't do
it any better than that you see the ball
off the plate and it just catches the
corner so with two men out the rays have
put two men on on the single by brandon
lau and the walk to mike brosso and
that's going to get low up there
runners lead the stretch cobb pitches
swinging and lining it into right for a
base hit hit hard now around third he
heads for home to throw to the plate is
cut off throwback to second and brasso
is back in there it's one nothing raise
on a first-inning rbi single by nate
lowe tyler glass now has been staked to
a one-nothing lead 46 in the third
innings how about the strikeout 73
punch-outs he's averaging 14.2
per nine
one two
and that is strike three
98 knees toward the inside corner
pitchnell
is on the way fastball struck him out
swinging
and the breaking ball gets him a cut and
a miss
and the orioles have loaded the bases
with nobody out there's brian holliday
that's a strike call out the knees 99 on
that one and holliday is caught looking
with a good opportunity here they loaded
them now here's andrew velasquez
two-two pitch fastball got him again
swung old and missed strength three
velazquez is retired and it's taken a
lot of pitches but there are two men
away now
there's a high fly ball well tagged
right field stewart in front of the
fence and that ball out of his glove
satsugo heads to third and the throw
will not be in time he's in there
standing up
here's lao left-handed batter now the
1-0 pitch there's a swing and a line
driving a right field that's going to
get down for a base hit stewart plays it
on a hop yoshi comes jog at home touches
home plate it's an rbi single by brandon
lau in the raise lead is two nothing
here in the third
swinging a ground ball out to short
velazquez up with it throws to first for
out number one
next offering swing and a miss
it's dropped by holiday on the exchange
but perez gives himself up the inning is
over and austin hayes will lead it off
works from the stretch raises the length
here's the pitch home swinging a deep
fly ball left field going back a rosa
rain and it's gone
it clears the wall in left field austin
hayes with his second home run of the
year and the orioles slice into the
tampa bay lead it is 2-1
he got a pitch in the middle of the
plate
and hayes powered it over the left field
wall
and that's a breaking ball to take care
of ruiz
and the breaking ball he takes it for
strike three
so caught looking this time again only
on the breaking pitch
now the one-two pitch back door breaking
ball strike three called and that'll do
it
for the orioles he's racking up the
strikeouts he's got nine of them through
four
and uh this one is a swing and miss
ended up getting glass now his 10th
strikeout
98 pop down the right side who's going
to get it on the run in foul territory
hunter renfro and up into the net he
goes
renfro
tracks that one down off the bat of
alberto
for the second out
boy coming in to save the day that was
not an easy catch it looked like
everybody was ready and then you see the
reach and then this
well that's why performers have the net
and that's why renfro
used it to save himself after the cat
they're loaded
two down
ray's on top 2-1
going against a guy that's had a lot of
big hits against the orioles and mike
brasso a little roller up the line
fuller flips it over to mouth castle
and just like that homer out of the
inning
[Applause]
and the high fastball is skied into
right
that's renfro hunter renfro making the
catch one away
now a high fastball and stewart chases
that that's the first strikeout for
anderson
and he got him with a breaking ball
in the dirt
down to first to complete it one two
three
go the orioles in the eighth we go to
the ninth two one raise
and it's two to one as we go to the
bottom of the ninth and ryan sheriff
gets the call from the raised bullpen
pitcher number five sheriff the lefty
rocks to a stop he pitches swinging a
high drive into left field it is deep
going back phillips to the warning track
now comes in and makes the catch
there's one out in the ninth
ryan sheriff turned around as it to say
uh oh
and now he's all smiles
the orioles will use their final they'll
play their final card off the bench
is ronaldo nudes
and it's pop back into right center on
the run margot he is there and makes the
catch the raise win this one
it's a 2-1 final
as the rays
have taken the first three games of this
series
from the baltimore orioles